MELISSA MUNOZ: Hi,
I'm Melissa Muñoz,
Program Manager for the Women
Techmakers team at Google.
I'm excited to announce our new
video series, "Women Techmakers
in 60 seconds."
This series, available on
the Women Techmakers YouTube
channel, takes topics,
technologies, and the skills
our presenters have
spent years honing,
distills their knowledge
into a format that's
fun and easy to digest.
We'll be publishing a new
video every other Wednesday.
So you'll meet a whole
range of women techmakers
from both within
and outside Google.
What can you learn
in 60 seconds?
Subscribe and find out.
Get alerts for new episodes
and, most importantly,
share the playlist
with your community.
We believe strong role models
inspire others to action
and remove imagined
barriers to success.
So spread the word,
share the link,
and help create a
more inclusive future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]